il avait 70 ans vous aviez ça 72 73
Charles Trenet à Rungis c'est une blague
et il était là effectivement et on a eu
un coup de foudre on s'appelle mon père
je suis papa il y a Charles Trenet qui
m'invite à passer quelques jours avec
lui on va on rappelle que vous avez 16
17 ans votre père est cool et papa voilà
et papa me dit mais écoute vas-y l'été
tous les thés tous les thés avec lui
ses vêtements parce qu'on avait la même
taille que vous avez couché ensemble on
a jamais couché ensemble et on a une on
a une liaison on a essayé une fois voilà
vous avez essayé on a essayé et au bout
de 10 minutes 5 minutes on s'est mis à
rire et on s'est pris dans les bras et
on s'est embrassé il me dit tu comprends
j'aurais tellement l'impression de faire
un inceste j'ai l'impression de coucher
avec moi-même mais vous vous m'avez dit
j'étais amoureux de lui sincèrement mais
si je suis très honnête j'avais 20 ans
et je couchais avec un monsieur de 70
j'avais envie de coucher avec des gens
de mon âge j'étais amoureux mais
physiquement et sexuellement j'arrivais